miami's set to become the most
vulnerable coastal city in the world
according to the economic organization
resources for the future and it's not
hard to see why
the city faces a constant barrage of
storm surges coastal flooding and rising
sea levels that if not addressed
threaten its future
if we get a coastal surge from a storm
or even a high tide it can flood this
area they're challenges that miami's
chief resilience officer works on every
day dozens of projects have already been
completed but the challenges are huge
it's an evolution
in the way we occupy this land
and how we deal with the water making
room for water that you know we didn't
think was going to be up on the land i
think we'll be here i just don't think
we'll look the same
that's a hard pill to swallow in a city
that's expanding and known as the
gateway to the americas but there are
glimmers of hope for decades miami's
been considered the city at the
forefront of tackling rising sea levels
and there's no question it is vulnerable
but many people point to this building
the perez art museum of miami as a
picture of what the future might look
like
sitting over three meters higher than
current storm surge requirements the
museum incorporates the latest in porous
materials water management techniques
and drainage okay well this is fun let's
do more of it despite the cost of
construction at well over a hundred
million dollars it's an example of what
can be done we knew exactly where this
building was going to be
we wanted to make sure it was here
forever and it starts right there what
are the needs of an art museum but what
are the needs when you are on the water
in miami florida
like many coastal cities miami city
planners are finally taking action with
some architects envisioning a very
different relationship with the rising
seas
designs like this may be revolutionary
but experts say the alternative is
unthinkable we have an opportunity
hopefully to innovate and to think of
ways that we could live with water
and and still not have to pack and go
right because you know displacing six
million people you know in an urban area
is no easy task the challenges and the
costs involved are monumental but sea
levels continue to rise the city could
soon run out of options andy gallacher
al jazeera miami florida